so given that the trigger for the
endless calamity ability seems to be
whatever an individual believes it is I
would like to tell you right here and
now that your personal calamity trigger
is seeing this red subscribe button for
the new old review and the only way to
prevent calamity is to press it turning
it into this peaceful docile wonderful
subscribe button which will also result
in regular Jojo content uploaded
straight into YouTube feed hello and
welcome to the new alt review your
source for everything anime and manga
and it would appear to be that time of
month again you Joe Joe Leon chapter
which is very very exciting this one
kind of crept up on me I don't know
about the rest of you but it feels like
chapter 95 came out like I don't know a
week ago so this was a nice surprise and
in addition to that it was a super solid
chapter as well being endless calamity
part 2 and what I really loved about
chapter 96 in general is that we are
slowly but surely finally uncovering
this maddening standability
of the head doctor although it would
seem that every time we receive a new
piece of information it comes with a new
accompanying question to the point where
I'm now very much questioning whether or
not the head doctor actually exists and
in that regard I'm just curious is there
any doubt remaining in anybody's mind
that Tohru is the stand user here I mean
I personally still have a bit of doubt
now get into why but I've been very
sauce on this guy ever since he just
showed up that of nowhere at the
hospital because he's just too
intricately designed of a character and
this is far too late in the game for
random acquaintances to have time
invested into them with that said I
thought he was going to be more of a
surprise Lackey villain someone who had
gone under the radar but after this
chapter I'm getting to the point where
I'm pretty damn convinced that he is
more or less our head honcho responsible
for this endless calamity or at the very
least I think that is what the goal of
this chapter was to have us believe
and it's because just about everything
in this chapter feels like it's designed
to craft a narrative arrow straight into
his general direction so for example
mama Zuko and delightful cult plant
appraiser who I will talk about later
posits the initial idea that this black
suit clad figure is indeed the stand
itself perhaps even an automatic type
tracking its victims based on some sort
of vaguely defined criteria and what
this chapter also made extraordinarily
clear is that the head doctor figure is
definitely in multiple locations at once
which I'm not sure was obvious prior to
this chapter I mean yeah maybe it was
and I'm just a fool for missing it
that's entirely possible but the cover
page of chapter 96 also goes on to give
this game away by having multiple
figures so mama Zuko obviously has the
right idea and as such this has turned
into one of those search for the stand
user battles
and so immediately after my Mizuki
proposes this idea to himself we cut to
Yassa ho-hoo phones Toru which is our
first gigantic hints that he is more
than what he seems to be even without
examining his art yet because it's just
intriguing juxtaposition you know saying
something like the stand user is out
there somewhere and then immediately
cutting to a scene focusing on this
seemingly unassuming character and just
look at the very first panel we see if
Toru with those cold dead eyes what a
close-up there's something quite
terrifying about seeing an IED devoid of
a pupil and it's almost as if there's
something you know not quite human about
Toru and in this panel he is clearly
lacking any form of empathy which is
kind of strange given how he professes
to love y'all Suho and how much trouble
she is currently in it's almost as if
this call isn't exactly a surprise to
him and that gets further reinforced
throughout the page as Tori weaving
continues eating lunch so for someone in
the midst of an endless calamity he's
pretty damn casual about this whole
situation actually you know what if he
does become a primary antagonist then
this is a great opportunity for Yasuo to
score some narrative points by defeating
him or at the very least it might put a
genuine romantic twist to the forefront
of the story with some sort of eventual
clash between josuke and Tohru
effectively boiling down to some kind of
fight over Yoho although who knows maybe
Tohru doesn't have any feelings for her
whatsoever and he's just acting - so
cows into Joe's case party either way it
seems like the whole josuke also her
situation is going to receive a fair bit
more focus in the very near future as a
result of well whatever is going on here
now I will say the one thing that does
give me some pause for thought about
Tohru
and this could just be me while they're
overthinking things is I have a tendency
to do from a meta perspective but it's
that he might be set up to be a red
herring
there's just something intriguing about
how obviously this chapter lays out the
idea of him being the stand user I mean
it never literally states that Tohru is
the wielder but everything is clearly
designed to point in his general
direction and that is something to be
potentially wary of when you're involved
in the mystery genre if you are ever
getting the answer just laid out in
front of your eyes on a delicious silver
platter then often it can be a trap to
subvert your expectations and throw
something else at you instead however I
do accept that I am probably greatly
overthinking this idea and for the
reason I stated earlier in that we are
far too deep into the end game of Jojo
Leon for this sort of twist to happen
but then again I've never really been
able to predict our key in any giorgo
experience least of all Jojo Leon so
yeah we'll see where this takes us I
will also say though as many others
online
tohru's name also forms part of the head
doctors name being sucked or do in this
particular shot of him in Chapter name
six makes his hair look an awful lot
like the rim of a bowlers hat
in fact the curves are pretty much bang
on so I do think that this is a very
purposeful connection being made to the
head doctor by Archy given how
intricately he constructs his art in any
other series I would probably say that
this is a wild coincidence but not Jojo
but regardless of who controls it for
now the stand itself continues to be one
of the most fascinating things I've ever
encountered in the series especially
because even with Mama's Lucas
deductions there are still so so many
questions regarding even basic aspects
of it like how is the stand triggered
because it seems to work very
differently for different people like
for Josie and mozuku the trigger was
whenever they physically approached the
head doctor
and then for yo-ho her personal trigger
is seeing the doctors face while for
meat Sabbagh it seems to be seeing his
back and now in this chapter with mr.
jail dude the effect seemed based on
Karma although he's the very cool thing
the whole karma train of thought was
suggested to the prison of my mama zu ku
who kept insisting that there was a
comic link between the individual and
the calamity which would seem to suggest
to us that the trigger for this stand is
essentially whatever a person thinks the
trigger is and looking back on the
initial head doctor chapters it's an
interesting idea because josuke and mama
Zuko do immediately accept that
generated hypothesis that pursuit is
what causes calamities but yah Soho on
the other hand seems almost entirely
immune to everything happening until she
looks at the doctors face so there's a
lot of really fascinating stuff at play
here and I do love the idea that mama
Zuko is using the prisoner in the first
part of the chapter to test a theory
regarding the trigger for the stand and
I wonder if he does indeed have that
knowledge and whether or not he will be
able to conjure an immunity to it but
speaking of that entire prison scene was
wonderfully cold and brutal I really
didn't realize just how much I'd missed
mama Zuko until he rocked up here and
displayed his stock brilliance once more
I also didn't realize how much I'd
missed his stand as well doggystyle it's
such a wonderfully versatile power which
reminds me of the craziness that Stern
free was able to achieve and using it to
sneak himself out of jail was very very
nice in fact the whole idea of escaping
from jail by irritating someone to the
point of self-harm well it very much
epitomizes who mama Zuko is and what a
compelling presence he is in Jojo Leon
the relatively light but completely
essential addition to the story in my
opinion now I've also seen some
discussion regarding whether or not mama
Zuko was the one responsible for
stabbing the
or isn't a wid doggystyle and to be
honest that is what I originally thought
happened as well just with how the
panels are structured at the rail East I
thought that until I saw what his
grander plan was in retrospect I highly
doubt that this was the case because it
kind of undermines the entire point of
my mizuka mentally pushing the prisoner
to that act of desperation so yeah my
reading of it is that the prisoner
self-harmed and immediately afterwards
mama Zuko activated doggystyle to hide
amongst his body to escape and really
that's very much how I would prefer it
there's something so terrifyingly
interesting about mama Zuko making this
happen without physically acting upon it
and of course we should also remember
that the whole calamity business was
also in play so that could have been
what delivered the final blow through
the prisoners karma trigger and that's
definitely not all because we do get to
make our way back to the higashikata our
estate and the good news is that either
noise gate isn't dead or job in her some
sort of revival plan for him involving
delicious fruit as everything in Jojo
Leon does and it's kind of crazy because
in this chapter Jobin is actually
portrayed as a reasonable and empathetic
individual which is in very stark
contrast to chapter 95 where it was as
if he had taken his final steps towards
becoming the pure antagonist and in my
opinion he probably still is even with
this whole head doctor business in play
I still don't see anything really beyond
joven it would need to be a super
last-minute antagonist if there were
anything else at all but he certainly
does not appear to be an antagonist in
this chapter he's just another guy
caught up in this calamity business and
it's interesting because he doesn't
appear to be able to see the head doctor
and also this probably gave us my
favorite part of the chapter with the
image of the head doctor making his way
across the hallway and the various
surfaces and this stuff is pretty much
right out of a horror thriller piece and
if a day ever comes when Jojo Leone is
animated this scene is going to be
creepy as all hell but in the end job
and decides to engage with the head
doctor or the stand or whatever it is
and I can't say that I see this
situation going particularly well for
job in at all if anything I think this
will result in job and also becoming a
victim here just with his own personal
trigger like perhaps every time he tries
to strike the stand
well maybe something much more
detrimental like activating speed King
in the stands presence in general oh you
know anything along those lines that
forces jobbing into a similarly
impossible position just as with all of
our our the main cast at the moment but
something I do very much enjoy about
this whole situation is that this really
is a potential moment for the cast of
Jojo Leon to come together and defeat a
true threat like this kinda reminds me
of the whole ozone baby situation but
josuke and Robyn's groups were affected
at the same time and
was this interesting three party dynamic
happening within that battle and the
sole calamity business puts out on a
much larger scale with significantly
more intricate elements I mean there are
so many separate simultaneous happenings
higashikata restate hazard in problems
Jos game mama zu qu are acting on their
own Elsa Howe is also on her own and
yeah I just loved how this is currently
being constructed as a story there's
great use of multiple threads here
happening by our ki and I'm very keen to
see how they all come together to
conclude this absolutely ridiculous
enemy before we hop into the inevitable
ending because I have to assume that all
of this has been taken care of by the
time we reached the flash-forward right
I mean from what we saw in the
flash-forward nobody has a single care
in the world so surely the head doctor
or whoever the stand user is has been
dispatched by that point and then we can
harvest ourselves some wonderful fruit
in summary though I think I enjoyed
chapter 96 far more than 95 which was my
first experience of reading juror
monthly last month had a lot of
traumatic OMPH about it with the whole
Norris case situation but the scope of
chapter 96 and the focus on whatever the
stand is has me completely hooked in
every way and as such mid-may really
cannot come fast enough although I do
hope that our current global climate
does not come to impact or Jolie on
which is serialized in ultra jump I
believe and I guess I just have concerns
because things have significantly
affected Weekly Shonen John as there was
a suspected case in their office but I
digress
Jojo Leon chapter 96 was nothing short
of fantastic and as such they eagerly
await more but what do you guys think
please do let me know in the comments
below and if you're keen for some
launchers or content then please do
check out some of my other videos we'll
even subscribe to the channel for
regular George or Wanda delivered
straight into your YouTube feed but for
now this has been the new alt review and
I'll see you next time